the democrats have abandoned
recent efforts to reach an agreement on
bipartisan immigration reform
saying that after ten meetings with
the republicans they still have not reached
an agreement that is why the
democrats are now trying to
pass immigration reform as
part of the package of
the president's human infrastructure I agreed that it would
only require the support of the
democrats and that they approve it through
the budget reconciliation process
the immigration proposal
includes a path to citizenship for
approximately 8 million
undocumented immigrants including
dreamers people with status  of
temporary protection known as tps and
to those who are classified as
essential workers during the
pandemic but the parliamentarian of the
senate has to decide if the
immigration package qualifies to be included in
the budget reconciliation process
if the parliamentarian says that
the immigration package  or if it can be
included the democrats will have to
convince all members of their
party to support the package
senator arizona christensen ama for example
was working with
republican senator jon cornyn on a
bipartisan immigration package despite that
the leader of the  democrats senator
chuck schumer told me this week that he
is confident that all members
of his party in the senate would support
this immigration reform reporting in
washington alexandra limón